No,
I finished up a celebrity apprentice.
I finished,
uh,
I came home,
um,
I had,
uh,
a book of my reading list that was a
Daniel Kahneman's book thinking fast and
slow,
opened it up and started reading and
realized I was reading kind of two
things at once.
An explanation of what I gone through on
celebrity apprentice and the best magic
book I ever read.
I don't think the annual condom and knew
he was riding a magic book.
I don't think he knew he was running
about celebrity apprentice,
but he might have,
when I was on celebrity apprentice,
I would see people who I knew fairly
well,
uh,
and I would see them acting in ways that
I found a wrong for their personalities,
inappropriate.
Uh,
I found,
um,
embarrassing at times and I couldn't
figure out why when you're outside of
the whole thing you say,
well,
they must be giving them a lot of
alcohol,
which alcohol is always available,
but most people in my team didn't drink.
So that doesn't work.
So maybe you're telling people that
crazy because it'll make better TV.
That wasn't happening either.
No one ever talked to me about that and
then I read,
and this is not economists work,
he was quoting someone else.
He just kind of brought it together for
me.
He talked about a ego depletion,
ego exhaustion,
and it turns out that if you just put
cameras on someone like you're doing to
me here and you asked them to talk,
they will speak a little clearer,
a little better,
a little more carefully than they would
if there were no cameras around,
but that only works up to a point and we
tend to think of or I always tended to
think about a new data about anybody
else.
I always tended to think of some
willpower as a character trait.
My mom would talk about,
you know,
pen,
you have to have willpower,
willpower,
you have.
Self control was very,
very important to my family,
very important and I thought of as a
character trait.
This is something that maybe I'm born
with some of it,
but I also want to develop and the mind
blowing thing about thinking fast and
slow reading that book was that it is
not a character trait.
It is not a,
a,
a quality,
it's a,
uh,
it's a muscle,
the ego,
the sensor that the,
the,
the thoughtful part of us that controls
us,
the self control is something that
requires effort and a lot of effort and
after you've used that for awhile,
if they may,
if you make someone very,
very careful about what they say,
four hours,
they walk by a piece of chocolate cake
and they're on a diet,
they'll still eat the chocolate cake.
When I was on celebrity apprentice with
the camera's on me all the time and
carefully watching my move,
I did not make any attempt to eat
healthy cheeseburger,
French fries every single lunch.
I just don't have the energy to use
myself control that way.
And for me,
when my ego breaks down,
when selfcontrol goes away,
I actually get very quiet.
What I tend to do is shut up and if you
watched celebrity apprentice,
as the day goes on,
I am a less provocative.
I am less confrontational when I am well
rested and working and full of self
control.
I am very aggressive.
It's what I do for a living.
When I get tired,
I get quieter.
I don't have conflicts with people.
I have to push,
uh,
to be an asshole.
Um,
other people who were very,
very nice and was images were very nice.
Uh,
the,
I mean they're,
um,
they're a public image,
is very pleasant and sweet.
After these cameras were on them,
you know,
for a five,
six hours,
all of a sudden that what I'm calling a
muscle,
that selfcontrol would just be exhausted
and they would just spew out anything
was popping into their heads,
really angry,
squabbling and yelling and pressure.
And it was a fascinating way to look at
it.
And it never crossed my mind that what
was happening was not some sort of
mental illness,
but simply a kind of,
um,
uh,
lack of,
selfcontrol caused simply by this ego
exhaustion,
which is very different.
I'm not saying that well,
the way I understood condiments book or
the section of the book is,
is not that they were physically tired
or even mentally tired,
but that self control,
that ego part was tired.
That part that says you will kind of
want to do this,
but you should probably do that.
Um,
it was fascinating.
And I,
the first thing I did when I read the
Daniel Kahneman book was I bought copies
for all the producers on celebrity
apprentice and send it to him.
He said,
oh,
by the way,
this is what you're doing.
You know,
and it's very funny that condom and
talks about all these studies that have
been done where they put people in a
room with TV cameras and had them do
tasks to watch how they acted and said,
you know,
they could have just saved a lot of
time.
They could have just turned on the
television.
Almost every show is a reality show and
they're all based on that technique
that,
that kind of Anti Hawthorne effect that
after your watched for a little while,
you do better.
And then it all falls apart.